in mha quirks have always been the most
important source of power and many of
the strongest characters in the story
were those who could use multiple quirks
like Deku all for one shigaraki Makia
and more once all might lost the ability
to use one for all after handing it over
to his successor Deku he effectively
became one of the weakest characters in
the series but thanks to a new amazing
advancement in combat technology all
might have been able to surpass the
power of quirks after David and Melissa
Shield hooked him up with a custom
armored battle suit that makes him look
like Iron Man all might have been able
to face off against all for one and his
many quirks without having a single
Quirk of his own that's because the new
battle suit can mimic the quirks of
others and it allows all might to use
them in battle subscribe to anime outpro
right now for more mha content